today on the matt wall show blm lies and
fabrications lead to more protests and
as we have learned of course facts don't
matter to black lives matter but
here's a really crazy idea maybe instead
of blaming police for choices that
criminals make we should
start at some point to consider blaming
the people who actually make the choices
i don't know
also five headlines including a joe
biden race baiting california democrats
moving to decriminalize peteristy
and harry and megan sign a netflix deal
and promise to make
some of the worst programming the world
has ever seen i'm sure finally
in our daily cancellation we're gonna uh
we're gonna talk about the black
college professor from quote the hood
who just confessed to being a white
jewish girl from suburban missouri
so lots of lots to cover today but we're
gonna begin with our good friends
over at rock auto listen it's still hot
out um you know we aren't out of the
woods yet with the heat especially
because of global warming they tell me
so
that's why you don't want to be waiting
around at the shop for your car to be
done
rockauto.com is so much easier much
better solution you could take advantage
of it from
the air-conditioned comfort of your home
unless you don't have air conditioning
you absolute savage rockauto.com always
offers the lowest prices possible rather
than changing prices based on what the
market will bear
like airlines do like a lot of
industries do you know why sped up to
twice as much for the same parts
here's what i really love about
rockauto.com most of all it's a family
business they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years go to
rockauto.com
to shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers
there's a huge selection and uh best of
all prices
at rockauto.com are always reliably low
and they're the same you know no matter
if you're a professional
do-it-yourselfer whatever it is
why spend up to twice as much for the
same parts the rockauto.com catalog is
unique
easy to navigate and you could quickly
see all the available parts for your car
or vehicle and you could choose from the
brand specifications and prices you
prefer
so that's what it comes down to amazing
selection reliably low prices
all the parts your car will ever need
rockauto.com
go to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car truck
wright walsh in there how did you hear
about us box
so that they know that we sent you
okay or that i sent you really
specifically that's what this is about
now i would um you know i would say that
protests
erupted in dc this week over the
officer-involved shooting of a black man
but that would be
the wrong way to put it protests could
not erupt because they were already
happening cities across the country have
been in a state of perpetual protest for
weeks and months now
new events are simply tossed like more
logs into the fire protests are not
protests are not really in response to
the events it is more that the events
are fabricated to feed the protest
so this time word was spread on social
media that a
quote child had been shot quote in the
back by police
blm activists took to the streets
ranting and raving about the
cold-blooded execution of an innocent
kid
witnesses on the ground well not not
witnesses of the event but witnesses to
other alleged witnesses who supposedly
saw it or heard about it or
heard from someone who talked to someone
who saw it
they said that the quote child was also
quote unarmed
so here's one such witness thrice
removed reporting
what she saw or rather what she heard
about
from other people who supposedly saw it
listen to this
i'm actually servicing a group of
students and we heard shots fired
and we came over to see uh different
police and we found out a 17 year old
was shot
by the police officer and do we have any
details
um from the community on on what
happened
um one thing is the young man with
unarmed
that's one detail and the everyone is
just heartbroken right now
and in disbelief that a police officer
would take a young man's life
i some people were saying he was shot in
the back is that something can be
verified or is it too early to say
um i guess it's too early that's too
early to say um because there's been
some things where he was sat in the back
and then you've also heard that he
reciting his chest
so it's too early to say yes the one
thing we know for sure
is that he was unarmed that's the one
detail we know that's the one thing we
can say for sure based on the
unassailable testimony of some
random people on the street who i just
talked to 12 seconds ago
but as we are of course stuck here in
this eternal time loop like groundhog
day but with
more racial strife and less bill murray
the next part of the story unfolded
you know exactly as expected almost
everything we heard from the activists
and supposed witnesses was false dc
police held a press conference on
thursday
released the body cam footage of the
officer who filed the fatal shot
in fact let's go to the press conference
here's the police chief describing
what actually happened yesterday at
about
3 49 p.m uniformed
members of the 7th district were in the
area of the 200 block of orange street
southeast to investigate the report of a
man
in possession of a gun officers had
seen a live stream of video on social
media of the man with the gun
and knew him from previous contacts as
officers
exited their patrol car to approach a
parked car that was occupied
by multiple men two individuals fled on
foot
and officers pursued them one of those
men brandished a firearm from his
waistband as he was fleeing
in response an mpd officer just
discharged his service weapon
firing a single shot at the individual
the individual sustained a single
gunshot wound to the to his chest
officers initiated first aid to the man
and members of the d.c
fire and ems transported him to a local
hospital where he was pronounced dead
the decedent has been identified as 18
year old dion
kay of southeast dc officers did
recover a firearm that mr we believe
that mr k
was in possession of at the time of the
incident in fact he actually understates
the case there
the body cam clearly shows that the
suspect dion k 18 years old by the way
not a child
is running towards the officer with his
gun drawn
let's take a look at that body cam
footage right now
don't move
hey shot just fired shots fire
[Music]
where is it where is it
i don't know i'm looking for the gun
he's up there
i did
[Music]
so he was not unarmed he was not shot in
the back
he has been been spotted earlier in the
day driving around town brandishing his
guns
uh kaye had shot a live stream video of
himself and his friends waving their
guns around
we're told that officers recognize kay
knew him to be as they put it a quote
validated gang member but none of this
matters
in our post-truth society those who
claim that kay was an unarmed innocent
child shot in the back by white
supremacists
only to find out that kay was actually
an armed adult gang member shot in the
chest by a hispanic officer while
brandishing his weapon
simply ignored the new revelations or
else seamlessly transitioned into a
news story about a remorseful suspect
who was just about to throw his gun away
before callous officers shot him dead
little effort is made anymore to come up
with a plausible narrative
you know we've reached a point where the
facts simply
do not matter period this was evidenced
elsewhere this week when protests began
again the word began is used loosely
in rochester over the death of daniel
prude
now he died several months ago after
asphyxiating
with a hood over his head while in
police custody
prude was in custody because he was
running naked through the streets at
three o'clock in the morning
while high on pcp the hood was placed
over his head because he was spitting on
the arresting officers after telling
them
that he had covered remember this was
also in march in the in the early days
of the covet hysteria
the medical examiner report lists
delirium and pcp intoxication as
contributing factors in his death once
again though
facts don't matter what matters is how
people feel
well certain people anyway doesn't
matter how the police officers feel
doesn't matter how business owners and
residents feel when their livelihoods
are destroyed by looters and rioters
npr just published an interview with
vicki osterweil
who's the author of a book called in
defense of looting
one of the dissent defenses she offered
for the looting in the interview not
making this up
is that looting feels good she says
direct
quote it provides people with an
imaginative imaginative sense of freedom
and pleasure
it helps them imagine a world that could
be and
i think that's part of part of it that
doesn't really get talked about that
riots eluding are experienced as sort of
joyous and liberatory yes it isn't
talked about
because it's insane vicky you psychopath
so the people victimized by looting
their feelings don't matter
that doesn't matter it also doesn't
matter how the past victims of lionized
criminals like george floyd feel
or jacob or jacob blake how their
victims feel when they see their
tormentors and abusers hailed as civil
rights martyrs
as it turns out feelings matter about as
much as facts
all that really counts is the far left
ideological agenda
feelings and facts are weighted
according to their usefulness to that
agenda
and i actually think this is an
important point to emphasize because
if somebody valued feelings over facts
they'd be wrong and irrational but if
they used that scale consistently and
applied it to everyone we'd have to at
least admit that they're empathetic
which is a positive trait empathetic to
the point of madness i grant you but
empathetic nonetheless yet when you look
at blm militants or writers or looters
do you see empathy do you see any great
concern for the feelings of others
when you look at antifa is that what you
see no
they are not only dismissive of facts
but also dismissive of the impact their
actions have on others
if they care about feelings at all it is
only their own feelings
nobody else's now in a world where
meaningful reflection is possible it
would be worthwhile
to step up to the side here and and
consider why events
like the dion case shooting actually
happen so pretending for a moment that
we live in such a world let me suggest
that
these events have very little to do with
police officers
all of the police reform in the world
won't stop
men like dion kay for getting themselves
hurt or killed if not by police than by
somebody else
amid the the panic over police police
shootings and the never-ending
dissection
and second guessing of the actions of
police officers rarely
does anyone stop to ask questions about
the suspect
that's too bad because several very good
questions could be asked
speaking specifically of dion k those
similar questions arise in many of these
situations
we might ask why was he running riding
around town waving his gun around
why did he advertise his crimes on a
public forum for all to see
why did he run when the police arrived
why did he draw his gun
if he had made different choices
anywhere along that chain
he'd still be alive today if the police
did anything wrong
which they didn't it would be in their
reaction to the bad
choices of dion k with extremely rare
exception this is almost
always the case in police shootings even
the bad ones are in nearly every case
a bad reaction to a bad choice by the
other guy
yet we're never supposed to question
those choices the first choices the
other guy's choices
we're supposed to start our
investigation further down the line
this is why it's always concluded that
officers are horrible sociopathic
murderers because
we assess their reaction independent of
the thing they're reacting to which is
like
if i'm driving recklessly and i swerve
on into oncoming traffic
and you happen to be in the oncoming
traffic and so you swerve too and kill
someone
but the accident investigators
completely ignore my role in it
that'd be great for me but you're
screwed because now it will
automatically look like you were drunk
or reckless
when really the drunken reckless person
was me and even if you were drunk and
reckless making the whole thing much
worse than it had to be
it still wouldn't be fair to arbitrarily
absolve me of all blame and act like i
had nothing to do with it
and it's even more important in cases
like this to try and uncover the reasons
behind dion case behavior because there
are a lot of dnks in dc
and every other major city in america
there is if you like a
systemic problem an underlying problem
but it has nothing to do with the police
and the symptoms of this problem are
well known
crime violence murder drugs all these
things that plague these communities
that's why the police are more involved
you know in these communities and more
interactive
and why police and and why police
interactions are more likely to turn
violent
only a vanishingly small percentage of
arrests turn deadly but the more crime
you have in a community
the more arrests the more people killed
by cops
it's a very simple formula really it's
not confusing
so again the conversation must go back
to the crime why is the crime happening
if you have an 18 year old guy running
around town brandishing gums a lot
live streaming it on instagram
pretending like real life is a rap video
that he draws his gun on police and gets
shot
it is just the height of absurdity to
suggest that the problem is the police
and not the culture and upbringing that
led him to make those choices
now i don't know dion case specific
family situation i think i could make a
pretty educated guess but
what i can say is that for many guys
like dion k
they grow up without fathers in the home
they are missing a strong
male role model someone to show them
what to do
with all of that masculine energy and an
aggressiveness
someone to direct them towards healthy
outlets for the innate need they have to
be seen as tough
and strong and intimidating a desire
that all boys have a desire that should
not be suppressed
but rather directed if it's not directed
or perhaps harnessed as a better word
that's when very bad things happen
so in these crime-ridden communities in
the city
if a boy has no male role model no one
to direct
and harness his masculine energy he will
end up looking in two places for that
direction
one to his peers who are just as lost as
he is
and two to the media pop culture
especially rap music in those instagram
videos dion k
is literally acting out rap music while
listening to it
he is imitating it in real time
and that's unfortunate because the music
explicitly glorifies drugs violence and
criminality
what happens then when a kid with no
father
no male role model pumps those kinds of
messages
into his ears all day every day all
throughout his formative years
and lives in an environment that in all
the wrong ways
mirrors those same messages well we see
what happens
baltimore happens chicago happens dc
happens
but we aren't supposed to talk about the
culture the upbringing or lack thereof
no
no when a kid has a no father figure no
male role models
and his mind in his mind spends all of
its formative years marinating
in in messaging that expressly glorify
suicidal criminal behavior and then he
actually goes and commits suicidal
criminal behavior the issue is the
police
somehow just the police it's not a
problem of culture it's not a problem a
bad upbringing
it's not a problem of bad choices
nothing and no one else is to blame
but the police a man can make a hundred
bad choices in a day all leading to the
final bad choice of drawing a gun on a
cop
and somehow the cop is to blame for
everything all of it the whole chain of
events
nobody else nothing else nothing else to
see here folks just the police
that's the only thing to talk about
right
no no that's not the only thing to talk
about
there's a lot more to talk about and i
think it's time we start
talking about it let's get the five
headlines
[Music]
so joe biden went to kenosha yesterday
we'll get right to the uh
we'll get right to the inevitable joe
biden moment while speaking to people at
a church
uh you know he got away from race
baiting and throwing police under the
bus
for a moment to talk about taxes for
some reason but then
then he stopped himself and um
this happened 19 corporations
making a billion dollars a piece don't
pay a single penny in taxes
i'm not going to punish anybody but
everyone should pay a fair share
i can lay out for i won't now because
they'll shoot me but here's the deal
they'll shoot me yeah joe not the best
joke given the circumstances
earlier in the day uh the the biden
campaign
speaking of race baiting released an ad
and uh it is
i almost hesitated to say it because
there's so much competition but it is
perhaps the most disingenuous
and misleading political ad i've ever
seen in my life
here's how that went why in this nation
and black americans wake up knowing that
they can lose their life
in the course of just living their life
part of the point of freedom is to be
free from brutality from injustice from
racism
and all of its manifestations we have to
let people know
that we not only understand their
struggle but they understand the fact
they deserve to be treated with dignity
they've got to know
we're listening reforming policing in
this country
means creating a national standard on
use of force
and conditioning federal funds for
police departments on adoption
of that standard it's about reining in
qualified immunity
we hold police officers accountable
can't turn away
now is the time for racial justice i
believe with every
fiber in my being we have such an
opportunity now to change people's lives
for the better
it's about who we are what we believe
and maybe most importantly
who we want to be now is the time for
racial justice he says
at the age of 78 after spending like
five decades in public service
now is the time it wasn't before joe
you're just deciding right now is the
time
i mean you've just now decided that
white supremacist police officers are
out murdering black people
uh in droves and we should stop them did
you not want to stop them before
or did you only recently decide that
this problem existed
if so what made you decide that joe
i could ask the same question about when
you exactly decided that women can have
penises and men can get pregnant because
that apparently you believe now also
that seems to be a uh you know a rather
new point of view and
a kind of a strange point of view for a
person to adopt in their 70s
biden lived his whole life then got to
the age of like 75 suddenly he woke up
in a world
where racist cops are murdering black
people and men are running around having
babies
he never never mentioned anything about
any of this before now all of a sudden
though
he's talking about this has got to be
the weirdest flip-flop in american
history and the media never asks them
about it
he's never asked to justify it never
they never say hey joe when did these
hallucinations begin also in the ad joe
asks why in this nation do black
americans wake up knowing that they
could lose their life in the course of
just living their life
uh that what that's the case for all
americans and all people
everyone eventually loses their life in
the course of living their life
when else are you gonna lose it you're
gonna lose your life after you've
already lost it
are you gonna lose your life while not
in the course of living it
makes no sense but of course what he
means to imply
is that racist cops are prowling the
streets executing black people in mass
that's what he means to say there that's
what he's getting at
and again we go back to when did joe
biden develop
these paranoid delusions he never
mentioned it before
now it's a thing
because of course these claims um about
racist you know black people have to
live in fear because racist white people
are out
are out hunting and killing them you
know completely disconnected from
reality
there is no evidence of any kind
period to support it joe biden knows
that though
but um you know if he has to inflame
racial tensions and
you know all of that um in order to
grasp on to power so he can live the
last
few years of his barely sentient life at
this point
um you know having the power that he's
thirsted for his whole life and then
then then
he'll he's fine he'll do that he'll help
just
destroy the country on his way out the
door great guy great guy that joe biden
what a decent what a decent decent man
that joe biden is just such a decent man
[Music]
number two uh speaking of decent men
michael reinold the man who murdered
the trump supporter in portland was
shot dead by law enforcement yesterday
while they tried to arrest him
the u.s marshal say that he pulled a gun
while they were trying to apprehend him
and he was killed
and now i say this in all sincerity
you know i i really am curious to see if
rhino is the first white man killed by
law enforcement that blm decides to get
outraged about i really don't know
i have no idea it's kind of 50 50. if
they uh not that there's any reason to
be outraged by it but that hasn't
generally stopped blm in the past so i'm
just curious if they'll break their
policy of ignoring white death
entirely for rhino i guess we'll see
all right now to the daily wire
has the report as i
pull it up here it is the california
state senate passed a controversial
reform to its sex offender registry
monday
that would allow a young adult who has
gay sex with a minor to escape
registering in some cases for the sex
offender registry
based on a judge's discretion sb145
finally passed the 40-member state
senate by a vote of 23-10
after being introduced by california
state center scott weiner
weiner argued that the current law
discriminates against lgbt youth because
as the chronicle explained
under current law judge could decide
whether to place a man who has vaginal
intercourse with an underage teenage
girl on the sex offender registry
based on the facts of the case but if
anal or oral sex or vaginal penetration
with anything other than a penis is
involved
the adult must register as a sex
offender under sb 145 if a young adult
has gay
sex with a minor with a minor 14 or
older who is less than 10
10 years younger a judge will have the
discretion whether to place the
individual
on the sex offender registry
okay and as you heard there the
justification being given for this
is that um in in some cases
when a heterosexual man vaginally rapes
a child
uh they are not put on the sex offender
registry and so as weiner
is arguing here the same should go for
gay men um
i don't think i i really don't think i
need to
spend time explaining the problem with
this logic
but i you know i spend most of my show
explaining logic that probably doesn't
need to be explained so we'll do it here
too
the obvious problem here is is is if
you're going to pass a bill
to address this disparity the bill
should be a
one that that ensures that men who
vaginally rape children
go to jail and are treated and are
treated more harshly than they are
that's the problem
okay that's that's what we need to
address
if in california there could be cases
where a 24
because this is the implications you
could have a 24 year old man
raping a 14 year old child and
they they might not go on sex offender
registry for that that's the way the law
is set up
at least if it's vaginal rape you know
man woman vaginal rape um
or man-child i should say okay well
yes i agree let's pass a law about that
but let's pass a law that does away with
that insanity
and ensures that a man who does that
goes to prison how about i don't know
forever you know at a minimum i could
think of harsher penalties also
that we could consider but no what uh
what the democrats are saying is
no let's make it even what they're
saying is
if this kind of child rape is legal then
this kind of child rape over here should
also be legal
what kind of degenerate lunacy is that
and this guy has you know he's going
around in the media uh complaining and
making a martyr of himself because all
the death threats he's getting
of course death threats are bad nobody
supports death threats but if people are
angry at him
it's because he's trying to
decriminalize certain forms of child
rape
and the argument he's making in favor of
it is that well that kind is legal
disgusting ridiculous
repulsive but that's the democratic
party for you that's the democrat party
um not just in california but
everywhere all right let's move on uh
number four
i actually forgot number four i have
number four written down here for my
five headlines and i never wrote a
number four this is a professional
operation so we're gonna skip right over
number four
uh maybe we could type maybe number four
was gonna be maybe number four is gonna
be the
the uh atlantic story about
donald trump you've probably heard by
now or they're claiming unnamed sources
claiming that
donald trump is was insulting you know
wounded veterans and calling them losers
and
he didn't want to visit a grave of a
veteran
cemetery because he said they're losers
because they died
all unnamed sources no one on the record
and um
and it's you know if something like that
actually happened and he actually said
that
and you're in the administration or you
heard it then you go on the record
tell your story the unnamed sources
think no
and by the way at least five name
sources have come out
and denied this and said so you've got
all the named sources are saying it
didn't happen
only the unnamed sources are saying it
did so you decide how to interpret that
but
i'll tell you how to interpret it it's
bs okay number five prince harry and
megan
have signed apparently a mega netflix
deal uh they're going to be producing a
whole bunch of documentaries and other
shows
most of the content about themselves
presumably
um i'm just wondering who would want to
watch this
i don't know aren't these two two of the
most boring people on earth
and i say this i i'm sincerely perplexed
here
why would anyone care what they're doing
with their lives
who wants to hear from these two could
there be anything
less interesting than the story of two
rich people who don't have
jobs what i mean nothing against them
if i could have a life like that i'd
take it but i'm not going to pretend
that my life is interesting
what a reality show of these two
consists of what would be the conflict
that drives the narrative
they have a disagreement about what kind
of caviar to serve at their
two-year-old's birthday party you know i
i don't know anyway the la times has a
statement from the couple this is what
the
statement says our lives
both independent of each other and as a
couple have allowed us to understand the
power of the human spirit
of courage resilience and the need for
connection
though our work with diverse communities
and their environments
through our work with diverse
communities and their environments to
shining a light on people and causes
around the world our focus
will be on creating content that informs
but also gives hope
oh my gosh did they just call themselves
courageous and resilient
is did they just say the lesson that
they've taken from their life
experiences is the value of
courage they did didn't they
and it goes on harry and megan whose son
archie is 15 months old
added that making inspirational family
programming important to them as
is quote powerful storytelling through a
truthful and relatable lens
they say that netflix's reach will help
them quote share impactful content
that unlocks action what
they're also committed to amplifying
diverse voices in the front of
in front of and behind the camera as
well as diverse hiring practices for
roles or filling out their production
company i'm going to be sick
i would honestly rather be skinned alive
and thrown into a fire
filled with snakes burning snakes
burning snakes with hepatitis
i would rather that than spend five
seconds
watching anything these two produce
but uh congrats to them on their netflix
still i'm sure it'll be great
let's get to our our daily cancellation
for our daily cancellation let's
consider the story
of a woman named jessica krug it's a
story that throws a great many leftist
narratives into chaos all at once
and i for one am enjoying the spectacle
so jessica krug is a professor of
african
and latin american studies she's an
author and teacher and activist
she's written and spoken over the years
about her black identity uh she wrote a
book called
fugitive modernities which i'm pleased
to inform you is available
uh in hardcover on amazon for only 84.
in her bio apparently she um
describes herself as an unrepentant and
unreformed child of the hood
the only problem is that the hood was a
suburb in missouri it turns out and when
she called herself african and black all
those years what she really meant to say
is that she's white and jewish
krug published a lengthy confession on
medium yesterday titled
the truth and the anti-black violence of
my lies
and here's what she says to an
escalating degree over my adult life
i have a skewed stewed my lived
experience as a white jewish
child in suburban kansas under various
assumed identities within within
blackness that i had no right to claim
first north america north african
blackness then u.s rooted blackness
then caribbean rooted bronx blackness so
she really covered the gamut here
i have not only claimed these identities
as my own when i had absolutely no right
to do so
when doing so is the very epitome of
violence of thievery and appropriation
of the myriad ways in which non-black
people continue to use and abuse black
identities and cultures
but i have formed intimate relationships
with loving compassionate people who
have trusted and cared for me
when i have deserved neither trust no
care nor caring people have fought
together with me and have fought for me
and
my continued appropriation of a black
caribbean identity
is not only in the stark's terms wrong
unethical immoral anti-black colonial
but it means that every step i've taken
has gaslighted
those whom i love okay
so you see how she tries subtly
to get the rest of white people to share
the blame with her
she says that what she's done is the the
epitome of the myriad ways in which
non-black people use black identities
first of all speak for yourself there
jessica don't try to drag the rest of us
into this
it reminds me of the men who are caught
up in the me too net you know the actual
guilty ones anyway all three or four of
them
uh and how they would always try to
spread the blame around you know
and say things like well i'm realizing
now that there's a problem with how men
treat women no chief there's a problem
with how you treat them
inviting a woman up for a meeting in
your hotel room and coming to the door
naked except for an open bathrobe that's
a you
problem that's a you move okay most of
us have never done that or even
considered doing it so don't try to
don't try to implicate the rest of us
and it's the same thing here with crew
she she a lot of her statement
she talks a lot about what white people
do and whiteness this and why no
this is this is about you this is what
you did later in her confession krug
says
no white person no non-black person has
the right to claim proximity to or
belonging in
a black community by virtue of abuse
trauma non-acceptance and non-belonging
in a white community
the abuse within and alienation from my
birth family and society
are no one's burden but my own and mine
alone to address black people and black
communities have no obligation to harbor
the refuse
of non-black society i have done this i
know it is wrong and i have done this
anyway yeah you
you read this and you do feel sorry for
her while reading it because this is a
woman
driven completely mad by left-wing
identity politics
she really she's been driven into lunacy
by it
and um obviously though she tries to
spread the blame around unfairly
it is true that she's not the first
white person to pretend to be black
rachel dolezal is the obvious other
example sean king
and then related examples too like
elizabeth warren pretending to be native
american
um then also according to the left
anyway
there's a a far more wide-ranging
problem there's the ever-present
threat of cultural appropriation right
and this threat is why
centuries must stand around the gates of
blackness to prevent the enemy called
whiteness from infiltrating under the
cover of night and stealing you know
a hairstyle or whatever if a woman is
caught if a white woman is caught in
dreadlocks
the trumpet is sounded she she's stolen
the hairstyle it's been stolen
as if when a white person steals a
hairstyle it means that a non-white
person is going to wake up in the
morning bald wondering who took their
hairstyle
which doesn't make sense but regardless
cultural appropriation we're told is a
serious problem
and that raises a question if all of the
privilege in america belongs
to white people then why would they
reject
that identity if if white people are the
oppressors then
why are so many of them trying to assume
the identity of the oppressed
can you think of any historical
precedent for this can you think of any
example in history of a member of an
oppressed group
of an oppressor group pretending for
years to be in the oppressed group
can you think of an example where the
oppressed group is also at the same time
so admired and sought after that one of
their biggest problems is how the
oppressors want so badly to adopt their
styles and customs
this is not at all what you would expect
in a systemically racist country where
whites are the beneficiaries of inherent
privilege
it's almost like america is
not systemically racist and white
privilege is
a left-wing fable that falls apart upon
further inspection
almost now there's another problem for
the left here and that is the matter of
self-identity
another obvious question comes to mind
why can't
krug or dolezal or anyone else identify
as black
why isn't their self-identity legitimate
if they say they
feel like they're black and they
identify most with that community
who's to say they're wrong i mean i can
say they're wrong
i can but i can say it because i happen
to believe that our fundamental identity
is not something
that can be changed on a whim it's not
subjective our perception of our
identity is subjective but the identity
itself
our demographical makeup those basic
facts about us are simply
facts no matter how we feel about them
but that's not the position the left
takes
they say that for example a man might be
born a man with a male body male dna
male bone structure male everything else
and yet if he finds within himself some
sort of vague undefinable
feeling of womanness then he's a woman
so what if he finds a vague undefinable
feeling of blackness why is he not then
in black
why is he not then black um sure
you could say well how would he know
that he feels as black people feel to
say he
knows it because he feels it is begging
the question it's circular reasoning
he's not black and so his feeling of
being black
must be wrong and you're right but then
i point you back to the man woman
situation
same exact thing can be said or you
could answer that
our race is not a changeable part of us
we're born with it again true but again
i point you back to the man woman
dichotomy
you might say that it's uh offensive for
a white man to call himself black that
he's
making a caricature of that identity
that he that he's claiming something
that doesn't belong to him
again yes true definitely but again man
woman
same thing see there just is no valid
argument
none at all for denying a white person's
right to be black but not a man's right
to be woman to be a woman
in fact between sex and race if any one
of those things can be called fluid or
on a spectrum
it would have to be race certainly you
know
race can make a much more plausible
claim to fluidity than sex
you can in fact mix races a white man
and a black woman make a mixed-race
child
a man and woman though don't make a
mixed gender child
so this is yet another leftist narrative
blown to smithereens by jessica krug
multiple narratives and uh
it is why she is not canceled actually
far from it i appreciate her service in
exposing these narratives
it's the narratives which are all now
of course cancelled i didn't even do it
jessica krug did did it she's the one
who canceled it i'm just i'm just
noticing it
and passing along the message to
everybody else that's going to do it for
today thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening
have a great weekend a great long
weekend um and i'll talk to you next
week
godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
see you there